el acné es una enfermedad de la piel que
consiste en imperfecciones que ocurren
en su rostro cuello pecho hombros y
espalda
el acné es muy común durante la
adolescencia pero puede afectarlo
también durante la adultez
para mantener su cabello y piel bien
lubricados su cuerpo depende de
glándulas sebáceas las cuales están bajo
su piel
estas glándulas segregan una sustancia
aceitosa llamada sebo la cual cubre su
piel y cabello para prevenir que se
sequen el sebo viaja a través de los
folículos del cabello y a través de los
poros sobre la superficie de su piel
rutinariamente los folículos de su
cabello remueven las células muertas de
la piel cuyo sebo sale de su piel
cuando su cuerpo produce sebo extra y
células muertas de la piel se pueden
juntar y obstruir sus poros dando como
resultado imperfecciones en la piel
luego la bacteria que normalmente existe
en pequeñas cantidades en su piel puede
crecer en el sebo en el por obstruido
llevando así a una inflamación
dependiendo de donde esté ubicada la
obstrucción y si tiene inflamación el
acné puede aparecer como granos que son
folículos obstruidos que impiden el
acceso al aire espinillas que son
folículos obstruidos que se vuelven
oscuros cuando la obstrucción está
expuesta al aire pústulas comúnmente
llamadas barros que son folículos
inflamados obstruidos con pus
o quistes que son grandes dolorosos
bultos llenos de pus que se encuentran
en lo profundo de la piel
cambios hormonales particularmente un
aumento de la testosterona puede llevar
a una sobreproducción de sebo razón por
la cual el acné aparece frecuentemente
durante la adolescencia sin embargo
puede ocurrir en cualquier edad otros
factores que contribuyen al desarrollo
del acné son las bacterias ciertos
medicamentos y factores genéticos si
tiene un caso leve de acné su médico le
puede recomendar una loción sin receta
médica con uno de los varios
ingredientes activos
el peróxido de benzoilo mata las
bacterias
seca el exceso de aceite
y remueve los poros obstruidos de las
células muertas de piel el ácido
salicílico retarda la pérdida de células
de la piel para prevenir la obstrucción
de los poros también puede acabar con
los granos y espinillas
alfa hidróxidos como ácido láctico ayuda
a remover las células muertas de la piel
reduce la inflamación
y estimula el crecimiento de nueva piel
más suave
el sulfuro remueve las células muertas
de la piel y seca el exceso de aceite
estos son químicos fuertes que pueden
irritar su piel
siga las indicaciones para uso exacto si
los productos sin receta médica no son
efectivos su dermatólogo puede recetar
le una loción fuerte con receta médica
como vitamina a la cual reduce la
formación de las células muertas de la
piel en sus poros antibióticos tópicos
los cuales matan las bacterias en su
piel o una combinación de peróxido de
benzoilo y antibióticos tópicos
para casos moderados a graves su
dermatólogo puede resultarle un solo
medicamento oral o en combinación con un
tratamiento tópico estos medicamentos
incluyen antibióticos orales los cuales
matan las bacterias y reducen la
inflamación e isotretinoína la cual es
usada sólo para los casos más graves se
le puede dar una inyección de
corticosteroides para aliviar su dolor y
ayudar a curar una lesión grande en
particular para las mujeres se les puede
recetar píldoras anticonceptivas que
contienen estrógenos para minimizar los
efectos de la testosterona a pesar del
tratamiento que su médico recomienda un
buen cuidado de la piel es esencial por
ejemplo limpie las áreas problemáticas
dos veces al día con un jabón suave y
lave cuidadosamente sin frotar si tiene
piel seca o escamosa usa un humectante a
base de agua y libre de aceite cuando
escoja un producto que es para su piel
verifique que en la etiqueta diga libre
de aceite o no comedogénico lo que
significa que no obstruirá sus poros
evita reventar o apretar las
perfecciones ya que estas acciones
pueden ocasionar una infección o
cicatrices evite tocarse el rostro con
sus manos cabello u otro objeto como los
celulares